according to legend house targaryen
survived the doom of valyria thanks to
danny's the dreamer who foresaw the
calamity and convinced her father to
flee their homeland
it could be true the targaryens were
always a bit
more this world wasn't always so
small and petty thousands of years ago
while the rest of men prayed to gods
the valyrians became them
through magic or sheer will they
mastered the greatest creatures in
history
a horse grants man dominion over the
land a ship
over the sea but dragons
gave us the sky and everything
and everyone beneath it
at its height my ancestors ruled the
known world
whatever parts we didn't weren't worth
knowing
our capital of valyria shamed the
magnificent cities of the east
for hammers and chisels were no match
for dragon fire
and sorcery it was a city
and an empire built to last until the
end of time
it didn't 400 years ago the dune
fell on valyria mountains cracked open
like eggs
lakes and rivers boiled fountains of
fire
ash and smoke spewed from the ground so
high
and so hot that even dragons burned in
flight
the land splintered and the angry sea
rushed in
in hours the greatest city in history
became history but my ancestors
didn't burn or drown with the rest of
their race
twelve years before the dune despite the
sneers of his rivals
ena targaryen abandoned the capital with
his family
legends claimed that his daughter
foresaw the destruction of the city in a
dream
more likely aina met with some mishap at
court and chose
exile over execution he and house
targaryen
slinked away to a dreary remote
god-forsaken island
forsaken no longer
with arts now lost to the world we
transformed a tiny outpost
into dragonstone a fortress fit for the
last dragon lords
then ainar's descendants settled into it
like a tomb
for their lost homeland
until aegon when he looked east
he saw the past old tired
dead but when he looked west
he saw the future gold in the ground
gold in the fields and no dragons in the
sky
but his he and his sisters rhaenys and
visenya
flew over the great continent ostensibly
visitors to a strange land
but when aegon returned he ordered
construction of a massive
table carved in the shape of westeros
with all the notable rivers and
mountains that they had seen
a personal map of the seven kingdoms
then ruled by seven squabbling families
[Music]
house durrandon held the stormlands from
their seat at storm's end
due south of dragonstone house horror of
the iron islands
had also conquered and enslaved the
riverlands and ruled them from harrenhal
a monstrous castle rising on the shore
of the god's eye
how stark held the frozen wasteland of
the north
the oldest largest and emptiest of the
kingdoms
house lannister held the westerlands the
wealthiest kingdom
thanks to their gold mines house
gardener held the reach
the second wealthiest kingdom thanks to
their crops
house aaron held the veil or rather the
veil held them
the mountains were impossible except
through the bloody gate which had never
been taken
house martel held the deserts of dawn
probably because no one else wanted them
together the seven kingdoms made
westeros a realm that wasn't yet around
ruled by great families who didn't know
what greatness was
aegon would teach them
though house during untitled themselves
storm kings they were little more than
gusts
their kingdom in the stormlands had been
doddering to its end for the past few
centuries helped along by
other houses most of all by house horror
who were nearly finished with a
monstrous castle at harrenhal
too large and too costly a seat to rule
only the riverlands
king argilac knew where the ironborn
would soon turn
you'd think a king who wanted to keep
his crown would be wary of a man with
five breathing monsters
but king argilac darunden wasn't called
the arrogant for nothing
determined to arrest his family's
decline he sent an envoy to dragonstone
to enlist aegon targaryen and his
dragons against his enemies
in exchange agalek offered lands he
didn't have
and a wife aegon didn't need for as the
valerians did aegon had wed his elder
sister
visenya then as the valerians didn't he
took the younger rhaenys as well
two sisters two wives perhaps that's why
he was so keen to get off dragonstone
aegon countered argilac with courtesy
he sent his own envoy requesting that
princess duranden's hand be given
instead to aegon's closest friend
and rumored half-brother orris baratheon
answered with a box and a note these are
the only hands your butt shall have of
me
inside the box were the hands of aegon's
envoy
how long had aegon been waiting for such
a pretext
as his army prepared to sail ravens flew
to every great lord of the seven
kingdoms
all bore the same message from this day
forth there would be but one king in
westeros
those who bent the knee to aegon of
house targaryen would keep their lands
and titles
those who took up arms against him would
be thrown down
humbled and destroyed poor old argilac
he couldn't even match aegon in
arrogance aegon landed at the mouth of
the blackwater river
and raised a primitive aegon fort in the
disputed land between harrens and
argilac's kingdom
so that neither could decide whose
problem he was
adopting the customs of the seven
kingdoms aegon unfurled his own banner
with the red
three-headed dragon breathing fire upon
a black field
visenya crowned him with a ruby-studded
circlet of valerian steel
while reigners hailed him as the first
high king the continent had seen since
the dawn age
as his lords and the gathered locals
teared him aegon named his loyal friend
to a small council
led by oris baratheon whom he called my
strong
right hand the title stuck and above
became the first
hand of the king but for now aegon's
kingdom
contained only a rocky island and a
handful of fields
the other kings had larger armies ships
castles and thousands of years of rule
but aegon had dragons he had chosen for
the words of his house
fire and blood before he was done
the rivers fields and skies would turn
red
aaron of hazor inherited a kingdom that
stretched from the iron islands to the
triton
too great a kingdom to rule from a
castle as shittiest pike
for 40 years his ironborn plundered the
riverlands for stone
timber and slaves to build the seat
worthy of him
legend has it that masons laid the final
stone in arnold
on the very day that aegon landed in
westeros
could have been a divine owen
could have been the masons once for the
dragons got there
they weren't the only ones at aegon's
approach
parents riverlords revolted led by house
charlie
i thought heron noticed harrenhal
could repel an army of a million men no
ladder could summon its walls
and no ram could shatter them the castle
was as impregnable as an old mates
aaron shut his gates around himself his
sons and his ironborn
and waited for aegon's army to drain
back into the muck
when aegon finally saw the monstrous
castle he asked for parley
harren granted it valeria had been the
greatest empire the world had ever
seen aaron wanted to piss on its ashes
yield now and you may remain as lord of
the iron islands
yield now and your sons will live to
rule
after you you see my army outside your
walls
you see my dragons
what is outside my walls is of no
concern
those walls are strong and thick
dragons fly
but stone doesn't burn when the sun
sets your line shall end
aaron spat and returned to his castle
once inside he promised lance riches and
tally's daughters to whoever could bring
down
aegon or his dragon as the sun sank
below the horizon
all of heron's men patrolled the
battlements
hearing wings in every gust of wind
but the moon rose and sank
and no dragon appeared while the
ironborn were ringing the battlements
aegon drove his dragon bellerion higher
and higher in the night sky so that even
the great castle of heron hall looked
like an ant hill below them
then they plunged straight into the
castle well inside the guarded walls
the five towers of heron hall reached
towards aegon like a hand
valerion opened his mouth and bathed all
the fingers in flame
was right stone doesn't burn
but men do even when they're ironborn
[Music]
the dragon blasted my ancestors into ash
that choked the survivors when they
screamed
harren soldiers leapt from the
battlements and died
they huddled against the walls and died
they
fled across the yard and died
aaron and his sons took shelter inside
the castle
stone didn't burn but as valerian
blasted it with fire it blowed white hot
the world's greatest castle became the
world's greatest
oven baking the last of house aura
within it
outside the castle walls the towers of
heron hall
glowed red against the night and began
to twist and melt
like five huge candles with liquid stone
trickling down their sides like wax
the next morning aegon forged a new
riverlands
he named the rebel edmund tully as his
lord paramount of the trident and had
the other riverlords swear him fealty as
their new liege
for centuries house horror had
terrorized the riverlands
under house tully the riverlands would
at last return to peace
and prosperity after the castle cooled
enough to allow men inside
aegon ventured into the ruin he'd made
of hair and horn
he saw the ashen bodies the scorched
stone
and the mangled and melted swords of his
former enemies
to his men's confusion he ordered these
useless swords collected and sent to his
aegon fort
while aegon marched on harrenhal after
his coronation
auris baratheon had taken most of his
forces and his queen rhaenys with her
dragon
south to deal with the excuse for the
invasion argilac the arrogant
king of the stormlands argilac had his
seat at storm's end
a castle considered the most impregnable
in westeros after hiron hall
arguelac may have been arrogant but he
wasn't stupid or a coward
his lords advised him to shut his gates
and wait out the siege
but he'd heard what had happened at
harrenhal and refused to die
a suckling pig cooked in his own castle
he would meet victory or defeat the same
way
with sword in hand he called his banners
and marched to meet auras baratheon in
the field
thanks to rayner's dragon meraxes aureus
knew argilac was coming
how many men he had and how fast he
marched
so auras simply seized the high ground
and dug in on the hills to wait for
argelac
as the two armies approached the wind
rose to meet them and the rain poured
from the sky
a gale which would give the battle its
name the last
storm king argilac's lords urged him to
wait for the weather to die down
but a storm king saw that the rain was
blowing into the faces of the baratheon
men on their hills
and agilecard numbered the baratheon
host two to one
with four times as many knights and
heavy horse
argilac attacked three times
argilac led his knights against the
baratheon line
but the hills were steep and the rain
had beat the earth to mud
the war horses founded and slipped and
the charges collapsed
the battle seemed lost until argilac
ordered his spearmen up the hill
blinded by the rain the baratheons
didn't see them until it was too late
one hill fell then another and another
until only one remained in the baratheon
center
if argilac could break through there he
could split the invading army
and flank both halves argilac and his
men
charged and the baratheon line broke
revealing queen rhaenys and meraxis
aguilax vanguard burst into flame and
his men panicked
the victory charge fell into chaos and
aguilect himself was thrown from his
horse
but he didn't yield when auris baratheon
arrived
he found the old king holding off half a
dozen men another half dozen dead at his
feet
or is dismounted to meet the king on
equal footing and offered argilac one
final chance to yield
argilac cursed him instead as the storm
raged around them
the grizzled old warrior and the bearded
upstart fought for life and kingdom
in the end aguilar got his wish
he died sword in hand
as word of argilac's death spread his
lords and knights threw down their
swords and fled
ori sent his vanguard rode to storm's
end to claim
argilac's castle for aegon only to find
the gates barred and the walls manned
argilac's daughter had assumed his crown
and the new storm queen was as fond of
yielding as her father
she declared that auras would win only
bones blood
and ashes here but her men were weaker
than her
and that night oris found argilac's
daughter delivered
gagged chained and naked to his camp
agalek had refused to give auris her
hand
now auras could have any part of her he
wished but auris unchained the girl
wrapped his cloak around her and poured
her a glass of wine
he told her he would take the arms
banner and words of house durrandon to
honor her father's courage in the last
storm conveniently orris had none of his
own to discard first
the crown stag became the sigil of house
baratheon and storm's end their seat
argilac's daughter would even remain in
her home though as a lady
instead of a princess the stormlands
were now
aegons and as tribute aegon demanded the
swords of the man
auris had defeated for what purpose
arys didn't know
aegon now ruled two of the seven
kingdoms but he would no longer
be able to take the rest piece meal for
the first time in
thousands of years the kings put aside
their squabbles and joined forces
against a common enemy
my ancestor king lauren of house
lannister was head of the wealthiest
family in the seven kingdoms
when king lauren joined his forces to
mourn of house gardener king of the
reach
they had the mightiest army in history a
so-called
iron fist to break the would-be
conqueror
but while an iron fist can smash a man's
face in battle
you'd look silly hunting birds or beasts
with it
an aegon had a creature that was both
the kings had never even seen a dragon
let alone fought one
they had fought each other for thousands
of years and victory
always went to the larger army surely
a force five times that of aegon's could
manage one dragon
but aegon arrived with three
still the lannisters and gardeners hoped
for victory
the battlefield they chose was a wide
plane with firm ground and clear skies
perfect for archers and mounted cavalry
but neither of the kings spared a
thought for why the ground was firm
there had been no rain for a fortnight
which meant all the wheat and grass on
it were bone dry
perfect for dragons at first
the kings looked like they would emerge
victorious when the horn blew for battle
their armies swept around aegon's flanks
and there are iron fists of mounted
knights smashed through his center
before the dragons could even enter the
fray
but then hagen and his sisters took
flight and
unleashed their dragons not on the
soldiers but on the dry
fields all around them the iron fists
unclenched and became a hand outstressed
for mercy
as aegon promised he had none
more than four thousand men died in the
fires another thousand escaping from
tens of thousands returned home as
monsters burned and scarred beyond
recognition
house gardener never returned at all the
field
of fire as the singers call it claimed
the last of the gardener line
and house tyrell rose in their stead as
lords of the reach and wardens of the
south
as for my illustrious ancestor when king
lawrence saw the battle was lost
he rode through a wall of flame and
smoke to safety
or at least to a heroic capture day
later
where he laid his sword before aegon and
knelt
aegon true to his words spared him and
confirmed house lannister as lords of
casterly rock
and wardens of the west why wouldn't he
the lannister always pays his debts and
now we owed our lives to the crown
that was worth centuries of subservience
at least
besides aegon had a fetish for
collecting swords
not heads he added lawrence to the pile
his men had retrieved from the field of
fire
and sent them back to the aegean fort
with most of the south in aegon's hands
the best chance to throw back the
conqueror
now lay with the north if we cared
enough to try
unlike our southern rivals the stark
kings of winter didn't forge the north
into one kingdom
for glory or gold there is little of
either here
but to survive alone in westeros the
north remembered when worse than dragons
lay waste to armies
thousands of years ago the sun set on
the realms of
men and the long night began a new race
emerged from the ice and snow
the white walkers they demanded no crown
offered no
terms spared no life and the dead
marched with them
with humanity facing extinction a stark
sought out the children of the forest
most ancient beings in westeros and
convinced them to ally with the men they
once fought
together the two races pushed the
walkers back into the land of always
winter
and sealed it off from the seven
kingdoms with the wall
300 miles of ice stone and earth rising
nearly 700 feet tall
to guard it they established the night's
watch a brotherhood
sworn to defend the living from the dead
whose vows are raised both titles and
crimes
after the long night the north tried to
forget it belonged to a continent
perhaps through pride perhaps through
sheer ignorance
you never can tell with the north but as
news of aegon's dragon
spread torrensta the king of winter
knew he couldn't forget westeros any
longer and summoned his lords to
winterfell many fools shrugged off the
threat
while the rest placed wages on how long
the south would take to burn
tauren silenced them with a command to
assemble their armies and descend from
the north in
force as the kings of the rock and the
reach burned on the field of fire
the greatest northern force since the
long night crossed the neck
into the riverlands but when king tauren
arrived at the trident he saw
on the opposing riverbank the combined
strength of
all aegon's conquered kingdoms a force
larger than tauren's own by
half and with three dragons
that night king tauren called the
conference of all his lords and advisers
some wanted to fight and trust northern
valor to carry the day
and burn on the triton the wisest of
them
wanted to withdraw to moat kalin the
fortress which had thrown back every
southern invasion and burned there
one suicidal lord even wanted to ambush
aegon's camp in the dark
and kill the dragons as they slept or at
the very least
their riders it's hard to tell what
would have been
his fate burning beheading
dismemberment perhaps all three
my ancestors listened to their council
and in the morning crossed the trident
under a flag of pales
then king tauren of house stark laid his
ancient crown at aegon's feet
and was named lord of winterfell and
warden of the north
and the king who knelt he had no choice
and thanks to him our soldiers returned
to their homes
whole and unharmed the swords the aegon
took from them were not twisted
burnt or mangled yet
the veil of aaron was the last of the
great kingdoms left
old and proud house aaron did what they
always did in times of strife
they shut the bloody gate sealing off
the veil
then the queen regent shara of house
aaron retreated with her son
the boy king ronald into the eerie their
family's
impregnable fortress from the top of
their mountain they could look down on
westeros far below
its problems hidden beneath the clouds
but one day queen shara entered the
outer courtyard to find her young son
sitting on the knee of visenya targaryen
and ogling her dragon vega beside her
just as he'd asked for another cake at
dinner little king ronald asked his
mother if he could go flying on the nice
ladies dragon
visenya smiled at shara so
shara imagined did vega
remembering her manners jara asked if
she could have visenya brought some wine
or food she must be tired after such a
long flight
but visenya demurred bored with his
mother's pleasantries
ronald demanded an answer poor boy
he didn't even understand the question
sarah hesitated for a moment then asked
for zenya
as a mother if it was safe for the boy
visenya assured her it was
what choice did shara have whilst her
son
circled the castle she collected his
little ringlet
her own region's coronet and the ancient
falcon crown of mountain and vale which
the aarons had worn for thousands of
years
ronald had taken to the sky as a king
but he landed as a lordling
perhaps he considered his ancient rights
a fair trade for a few minutes of flight
as a little boy would
more likely he didn't even notice the
three
crowns at visenya's feet or recognize
the swords of his garrison beside them
the heads of westeros had bowed to aegon
but its
heart still beat free old town
the center of the faith of the seven
there dwelt the high septon the father
of the faithful
who commanded the obedience of all
westeros save the savages of the north
and their
old gods when aegon had landed in
westeros
the high septon had locked himself in
the starry sept and fasted for seven
days and seven nights
one for each of his gods all he received
for his trouble
was the divine wisdom that if old town
took up
arms against the dragon the city would
burn
faithful and faithless alike after the
submission of house stark
aegon marched towards old town stealing
himself for another battle
but he found the gates open with the
high septon welcoming him
the pious fool even had the arrogance to
grant what aegon had already won
and anointed the last valyrian as aegon
of house targaryen
first of his name king of the andals and
the first men
lord of the seven kingdoms and protector
of the realm
as if titles meant anything to a man
before whom time itself now bowed
the maesters would hence divide all
history into before
and after conquest
most expected aegon to stay and make old
town his seat
but soon after his coronation aegon
returned to the mouth of the blackwater
river
where he had first set foot on westeros
a small town had since sprouted around
his primitive fort
to honor their new master the locals
dubbed it king's landing
though it looked more fit for a hedge
night with wooden palisades
muddy streets and piles of mangled
swords
carted in from every corner of the
conquest
but when aegon made it his court wood
became
stone black mud was buried beneath a red
keep
and the collected swords of aegon's foes
were blasted by dragon fire
and became a seat fit for the conqueror
and the greatest dynasty this world has
ever known
house targaryen my family
my throne
or so it should have been
but while aegon titled himself lord of
the seven kingdoms
in reality he held only six the seventh
dawn had never knelt visenya had flown
into the veil and returned with its
crown
mimicking her sister rhaenys had flown
over the enemy force holding the passes
into dawn
and landed in the castle of its ruling
lady princess maria of house martell
maria was 80 years old fat bald and
blind
behind her back many sniggered at her as
the yellow toad of dawn
the beautiful renise probably thought as
much when they met she demanded princess
mary a neil to her brother aegon
though she allowed that on the count of
mary's age and health the simple vow of
submission would do
but the princess told the queen that the
targaryens weren't wanted in dawn
and no martel would ever bow bend or
break no matter how badly they burned
renise could have mounted her dragon
right then and roasted
maria in the castle as her brother had
done at harrenhal
but whatever she saw in mary's eyes
scared her right back to king's landing
with a dragon's tail between its legs
after aegon's coronation rhaenys
returned to dawn with aegon and visenya
and their dragons but no armies met them
in the field and no lords defied them in
their castles
as the dragons approached dawn simply
emptied house martel had learned from
harrenhal
and the field of fire the dragons were
unbeatable in battle
but wars were more than battles
unopposed aegon claimed dawn for his own
but as soon as he returned to king's
landing his castles were hurled off
towers
and his royal garrison vanished in the
desert never to be seen again
except perhaps when the wings change and
the sands cough up old bones and armor
renis returned on their axis intent on
revenging herself against
mary and martell but dawn was no longer
empty
the dornish kept maria's promise and
fought
even while burning under dragonflame
and they won one day a bowl pierced the
eye of maraxis
and knocked the dragon out of the sky
house martel remained unbroken
unlike the unfortunate rainers in their
wrath aegon and visenya set flame to
every castle and city but sunspear
trying to turn the people against house
martel but the dornish stayed loyal
and when aegon returned to king's
landing he found assassins waiting for
him in the streets of his own capital
if not for visenya the conqueror would
not have enjoyed his conquest for very
long
from then on the king and his family
would be guarded by the seven
greatest knights in the realm the king's
guard
when maria died in her sleep her weak
and tired son sued for peace
but old maria had exhausted aegon as
well
and he granted the request the targaryen
still wanted dawn
and eventually they would have it but
not at the point of a sword
they would buy it the same way great
lords buy anything
with a daughter
after the conquest when men looked up
they saw dragons
nobles learned to keep their eyes down
but the gods weren't used to sharing the
heavens
when aegon died the high septon led to
the faith and its army in revolt
claiming that the valyrian tradition of
wedding brother to sister was an
abomination in the eyes of the seven
though no one could explain where the
divine mother and father had come from
my ancestor make all the wise who make
all the cruel
as men slander him put a bounty on the
head
of every militant priest and
miraculously
the faith soon returned to the sects
with dawn in the fold
and the faith put in its place none in
westeros were left to oppose my family
so we started opposing each other in the
dance of dragons a targaryen
princess tried to steal her brother's
throne
thanks to her stupidity most of our
dragons died
though one thankfully ate her before it
did
but even without our dragons we were
still the blood of old valyria
which proved just as dangerous one of my
foolish ancestors didn't see what
separated his from our family proper
and legitimized them all on his deathbed
adopting the name blackfire proved their
nature
and tried to seize their father's
kingdom when they failed
their sons tried when the sons failed
their grandsons tried
until finally sarbarist in the bold
knight of the kingsguard
slew melees the monstrous in the war of
the nine penny kings
ending the last of the blackfyre line
ultimately without our dragons and with
our blood diluted by commoners
we fail to see the greatest threat
growing under our noses